in our special series school matters
we're looking at the toll the pandemic
is taking
on teachers as we've been reporting
teachers in the nation's largest school
district in new york city
are adjusting today to all remote
learning
a survey of teachers nationwide finds 28
percent
say they've considered retiring early or
leaving the profession
due to stress and health concerns this
comes when there's already a shortage of
qualified teachers
janet chamleon is outside of school in
chicago janet good morning
anthony good morning to you it's already
a tough job with low pay
but teachers are suffering even further
in this pandemic
a recent study here in illinois found 66
percent
say they feel more burned out than usual
in new york
with yesterday's lockdown order and the
shutdown order at schools
it's forcing teachers there to pivot
once again
it's like a snow day but indefinitely
high school teacher matt baker thought
new york city public schools might close
again
but didn't know for sure until wednesday
afternoon
you're like running around your room
throwing whatever you can think of into
a bag to make sure you have everything
you might need because
we don't know when we're going back to
the building baker teaches at the
brooklyn latin school
he worries eight months into the
pandemic some students still don't have
what they need
for remote learning it's really hard
because it's like well i can do i can
have the most amazing lessons and have
great outreach but if
if the doe doesn't give them a laptop
that can connect to the internet
consistently
it's just soul crushing a little bit
schools across the country have
implemented a patchwork of learning
plans
but its teachers faced with the pressure
to carry them out
david finkel's been teaching 29 years
he's never had one as stressful as this
we are end of the year tire we reach a
point near the end of the year where
you're like wow summer bed
can't come soon enough and and we
already feel that way
many of his high school english students
are remote others are physically in the
classroom
he's worried not only about the virus
i'm doing my best
to engage them and give them as much as
i can but i don't think they're getting
as much as they usually get from me
an illinois education association study
found 27 percent of surveyed teachers
said they've considered giving it up
because it's just too hard with distance
learning i don't want to leave teaching
but i also don't know when this is
going to be better i don't know when
it's going to feel
like i'm not making things worse
mariah cline is teaching at the same
suburban chicago elementary school
she attended as a child i felt such
guilt
guilt of i could be the one that gets
them sick
or if i don't watch them carefully
enough
they could get each other sick and bring
it home what do you want
parents and just the public to know
about what teachers are facing right now
we don't want to be seen like people who
are saving the world by going in and
doing our jobs
we just want people to understand that
it is hard
and that it's hard in a way that they
don't know
here in chicago the public schools have
announced that they will go back to
in-person learning in january
but that announcement came just as the
illinois governor was announcing new
restrictions in the state
to help control the virus this district
this the decision on schools rather
is being left up to the individual
individual districts
and anthony i know that this is a
subject you know very well from having a
teacher in your family
yeah janet i sure do thank you and it's
something we talk about constantly
because because teachers are having to
adapt
as the situation changes they're worried
about their kids falling behind they're
worried about their own health they're
worried about their kids health
and in many respects they feel taken for
granted i think you make a really good
point because teachers most of these
teachers have their own families yeah so
they're trying to coordinate their own
kids
your kids their lives it's too much
and not to feel that there's light at
the end of the tunnel and not to be
appreciated for the work that there
is there is light there is light i hope
that enough good teachers can hang on
because we need them because we do need
them but that discussion about retiring
is happening
all over the place because it's so hard
right tony they're trying to hang on and
then they hear okay now the schools are
shut down
i know we're based on a lot of big vague
calculations and
and it may be 2021 september before it's
all back to normal
that's a long time for them